what up guys welcome to the just pro
pearly things youtube channel
today i am talking about a topic that
i'm literally
so nervous to talk about because i don't
know if i'm gonna like say the wrong
thing
and i know people have a lot of strong
opinions on this but
i'm about to give my two cents and you
guys can take it or leave it i'm
talking about purity culture today and
some of the problems and the issues i
see
with it and i know you guys are when i
hear people say this is the problem with
purity culture i already think that i
know what they're gonna say like i think
they're gonna say oh it's not fair
that you tell that to women or you know
like kind of have more of like a
feminist the answer
to it and i promise you that is not what
this is
um okay so just a little back story on
like me
i
i went to 12 years of catholic school
and
i did the whole like i didn't even know
what it was like to not wear
uniforms to school until i was older
and this is kind of like what i learned
about like
about purity culture so every year they
would have
a like speaker come in right so every
year they would have
someone come in and like talk about
purity culture and one
of the speakers and i think their name
is like christina and jason like everett
or whatever came to my high school and
basically
this was a cup i'm like nervous like
guys
i'm like getting actually nervous to
talk about this um but anyways this
couple was like a husband and a wife
and they had two different perspectives
so the female perspective was
when she was in high school or younger i
don't know how young she
made some bad choices so she hooked up
with a lot of guys
and she just talked about like the how
empty like that led her to feel
and how like bad that
you know like what like mentally that
does and i think
that's really good because there aren't
a lot of women that like really openly
talk about like
the negative aspects of like having sex
casually because i don't think women are
really built to have sex
casually just my opinion i know there's
some
maybe some anomalies of girls that are
like built for that but i just don't
really see it
okay um and so the husband actually was
a virgin
and basically like she
gave her life to god um end up meeting
her husband and then they get married
right happily ever after and
i really like here's the problem
with that message right and then on top
of that she also built a career
off of this like she ended up you know
going getting paid to go to schools and
speak about this
and here's the problem with that message
you're telling girls
that they can basically make any type of
choice
any bad decision whatever and the only
repercussion
is gonna be like to themselves but there
aren't any repercussions like from the
world
and like what i would tell people is
if you're doing that like you're like
making the decision to like sleep around
like you might miss out on like a godly
guy
because like i'm sorry but most godly
guys and guys that have saved themselves
aren't going to want to date girls that
have like made
those decisions i'm sure that was like
an anomaly and i
you know it happens but
what they don't say is like girls you
could miss out on your husband the guy
you're supposed to be with
by engaging in those activities
but instead like they say it's not too
late and
it's hard because i don't like disagree
with that like i don't disagree with
like
people can change people can make better
choices but
what they don't tell girls is like what
like negative consequences can come with
it they just say you know what even if
you make those choices
go say sorry to god and
then you know a man of god is still
going to want to like be with you and
love you
and
i i don't think that's always the case i
don't
um but let me know in the comments if
you guys like agree
or you disagree because this is just
like what i was thinking is that
like this girl basically did everything
wrong and still got
all the benefits and i don't think
that's always going to be the case
for people yeah